the Joe Rogan experience how do they
mitigate when you go overseas the effect
of being over there too long because I
would I would imagine that the stress of
constant combat first so this is my
ignorance of it but this is what I would
think was that what ferns first it's
probably like you get better at being
calm and more accustomed to it but after
a while the pressure eventually starts
to crack you that it did just many many
many months over there dealing with it
you have to you have to decompress you
do and they have like decompression
windows at the end of deployments how
much would it look what a typical
deployment how long does it last
so I was over there for four months and
they do everything from or they've done
everything from three months to thirteen
plus for a Special Operations guys and
the reason being they do the shorter
ones is because of the operation tempo
you're doing so much and you're doing it
so quickly and they want you to be fresh
and they want you to be good at it
because they don't want that stress to
happen right what is that like this this
stress like what how does it affect
people because I mean I would assume it
affects everyone differently although
the but the process of being in harm's
way
consistently for a long-term I I joke
about it making everybody professionally
paranoid mmm like you're always like I'm
not always wound up but I'm always on
some sort of alert for things yeah you
know I'm always like I'm always thinking
about stuff I'm always keyed on to
what's that guy doing why is he doing
that right in a way that I don't I I
don't know why that's there I mean I
know why but I don't know what part of
my brain is saying what the [ __ ] is that
guy do is that hard to let go and
civilian life or is it just there
forever now I think it's there well I
think it's there forever I can't I don't
know it's still there
jersey Jacko's video he does he did a
video recently where he's like people
were saying why you looking over your
shoulder doctor he goes I'm being
tactical cuz I'm checking my flanks
yeah it's like what why he was in the
dark and he goes so the enemy can't see
me how come I don't smile I don't want
them to see my teeth that guy yeah it's
hilarious he's the best he is I love
that got it through he's so great he's
such an important person too because
he's both articulate and savage he's
both a brilliant guy who is wise and
humble and but also a [ __ ] gorilla
you know he's a legit savage yeah I had
the chance to roll a little bit with him
oh don't do that don't do that he was
with Andy and Ed uh-huh and was that
when he broke Doug's neck yeah yeah
terrified broke a bone in his next John
thought he had throat cancer he did once
the doctors tell anybody like yeah what
happened to you oh my god it's [ __ ]
Furillo I put me in a guillotine snap my
neck big like gorilla was nothing he
actually did a guillotine I think he
actually was he had his knuckle in in
Jon's throat doing something I think I
want to say John that sounds right I
think John did that I didn't full guard
that didn't know how to tap exactly this
was like going yeah I think John had him
in full guard I might be [ __ ] this up
and Jocko put his knuckles into John's
neck and was like using a neck crank and
compressing his neck from like either
the guard or maybe even side control and
then had a knuckle in the throat and you
remember he popped a bone it was from
the guard yeah I think I think I was
about like from me to you to this going
on he broke a bone in his neck no he's a
gorilla yeah big hairless gorilla yeah
you can't know how much do you weigh 165
you can't roll with that guys it's no
don't do that what was it like but I can
run away from him yes way from DT
doesn't run at all no it's terrifying
no just March after it was that it was
like I was wrestling around with a
sweaty piece of mahogany yeah big guys
that are skilled that's so humiliating
yeah a big guy that's skillful I've and
I've had that happen once in the past
like the I think I'm cool and then you
find out you're not because I'm not a
big dude right like bloody mind played
played I think Oh line at Stanford I
came home from an employment and I'm
like I got a little blitzed I was like
screwing around like at the time I was
like 175 and he picked me up from under
the arms and he was like you're real
strong for your size and puts me down
I'm like a god I feel so emasculated
you're real strong for your sides is it
too [ __ ] weird , and he was like he's
like 300 pounds yeah you know like six
five I'm I got crap those are huge
humans that's giant how often did you
used to I don't you don't so you just
did that one time with him did it the
one time with him well that's ridiculous
he's a [ __ ] multiple-year black belt
hey thanks Andy yeah and he's crazy
and he's obsessed he does Jiu Jitsu five
days a week that's when we were teaching
to skydive oh Jesus Christ
everybody's trying to die he's still
he's trying to get his neck broken
you guys are skydiving
[Applause]